体罰を容認してしまうとそれを乱用して
エスカレートしてしまう。そういう人が出
てくるからは許すべきではないっていうお
話だったんですけど、これについてどう
思いますか
?それはね、ソフトの問題でしょ?体罰の
問題じゃなしにソフトの問題だから悪は
必ずソフトで起こるでしょうからソフトの
悪い人うまく使えない人がいるからと言っ
て禁止するということは自動車事故を
起こす人がいるから自動車は禁止すると
いうのと一緒やで。だから悪い方のことを
狙ってやるんじゃなしにいい方を狙って
やるんだからそちらの方を残しといてで
悪い方のことが起こらんようにソフトの
トレーニングをしたらいい
。見てると分かると思うんやけど本能の中
例えば感情。これは会感が3つあるんやね
。恐怖、驚愕、怒り。この3つです。恐怖
は逃げる行動をする。怒りは立ち向かう
行動をする。だから罰は怒りでやらないと
いけない。体罰さっきほら動物行動学の主
攻撃の話をしたよね。攻撃を恐怖でやる
場合例えばキ祖猫をかむあれは恐怖で攻撃
をする場合やね。やってはいけないことや
。ネズミが猫に向かっていて勝てるはずが
ないんだから。なんかむちゃくちゃなこと
になっちゃうんやね。恐怖による攻撃は。
で、特に人間の場合、弱い人が体罰をやる
と相手が怖いからやっちまう。俺の言う
こと聞かん。俺の言うことを聞かんという
ことが起こった場合にそれに対して怒りを
出す人と恐怖を出す人とおるんやね。
あいつ俺を攻撃するつもりかという恐怖や
ね。そうするとところが立場が自分の方が
上だから体罰をやる。体罰をやってみても
恐怖が消えないじゃない。またいつか
やり返されるかもしれん。やったのに言う
こと聞かないで。それがエスカレートして
いくんやね。もっとやろ、もっとやれ。
もっとやれ。だから恐怖による体罰は
間違い。怒りによる体罰は正しいな。だ
から体罰をやる人は自分が恐怖でやっとん
のか怒りでやっとんのかよく湧きまえんと
。精神的に弱い人は必ず恐怖でやるから
やめた方がいい。簡単なことやろ。まず
やる方が己れをしれよろ。
で、その前にちゃんと罰ができるよう相手のためになるように自分をトレーニングしろよ。強くなれ。強いのは全、弱いのは悪だ。そいつを今ね、リベラルは弱い方が全、強い方が悪って言うじゃない。だからおかしなことになるんよね。
体罰をやる人によって、ま、効果とか正しく行われるかが変わると思うんですけど、そこはソフトの問題なので、罰自体の問題ではないっていうことです。
自体の問題はないよね。そこをみんな
間違えとるし。マスコミなんかもわけ
わからんよね。松明は虐待であるとか松明
は暴行であるとか言い出すようなアホと
しか言えんような連中よね。そんなやの
言うこと聞いたらいかんよ。大体ほら地一
知っているということはできるということ
か。正しい体罰ができる人は体罰を知っ
てるんだ。だけど体罰をやったこともない
人が体罰について語ったらそれ嘘や。
正しいかどうかの判断は全然してないから
、もう現場の人間以外がそういうことを
言い出したらマに唾をつけて聞いた方が
ええなかとかただ本を読んだだけの人が偉
そうなことを言うのがマスコミやからね
。
現場で体罰を行う人によってこう差が生じてしまうっていうのは罰のノーハウがあんまり広まってないからだと思うんですけど。
そうですよ。だからちゃんとした体罰をずっと続け取ればやる方もだんだんうまくなってくよね。やり方が必要な時にやるやり方感情でやる意思はこういう風に持つで持って罰やれば必ず効果があるわけね。
これは今学校の先生とかが罰しにくい世の中になってると思うんですけど、それでも罰を、ま、自分の子供とかスクールとかで行っていきたいって人はどう学べばいいと思いますか?
もう学びようがないんや。したら不になるからね。あいつらのリベラルのバカなとこなんよね。自分に反する意見を持っとるものは追放しちまうわけや。独裁やろてよう考えておらん。
今日本の社会はリベラル独裁になっとるから独裁はかんと言っとる連中が独裁やるんや土地狂っとるよね。己れが分かってない。
[音楽]
今後向的には体罰はどうなっていくべきだと思いますか?
とかと復活戦と日本がこれだけ潰れかけとるのにまたタご遠いって正しい教育を否定する奴らがイニシャブを持っとるんやね。残念なことにね。
民主主義っていうのは普通の権力者3件や
ね。司法立法行政に対してしか有効やない
やろ。で、第4権力マスコミに対しては法
がないんや。だからマスコミは読者がおる
んだからええやないかて言い出すよね。
あいつらはもう本当にやるしか方法がない
やないか。反省する力がないんやから
マスコミが1番いかんのだ
。
今校長と一緒に今までの教育のノーハウとかを作ったコンテンツを一緒に作っていこうっていうのを進めてるんですけど、体罰のやり方とかはその中にこう動画化して入れるっていうのはどうですかね?
体罰はね、感情を込めないと意味がないんだ。感情的にやってはいかんというバカがおるやろ。冷たいやろ。感情はこもってないと。それがわからんのや。連中は。感情を込めて罰をするから聞くんやないか。
あれはヨーロッパ流の地が大事だって感情は間違っとるんだというあれの延長なんだ。奴らの間違った精神論の元にそういう判断をしとるだけであって感情を込めてやったらよく聞くんよ。
感情に任せ罰を行うともう行きすぎた暴行に及んだりとかはないんですか?
それは恐怖でやってはいかんということや。恐怖でやると行きすぎるんや。必ず行きすぎるから。恐怖でいくら罰やっても相手が怖いんや。つまでったもんね。
だからつまで立ってもやっちまう。安からする。怒りだったら怖くない。
ありがとうございます。はい。
[音楽]
H